what do you think is the the number one  issue the pressing issue in the United  States right now well I I'm going to get  the answer I always give which for me it  is uh it's the life issue for me it's so  that's why I write about abortion 50  times a week because I think that  um how are we supposed to move on  to other issues when we haven't settled  the basic question of whether or not  life is valuable and if it even means  anything or if it's worth preserving  so to me that's it's a two-fold issue  it's number one you've got the actual  death toll which is  uh trumps any any other cause of death  many many fold  um but then also there's the  philosophical issue of  does life even matter if it does then  let's focus on if it doesn't then what  does any of this stuff